panique à l'idée un truc vrai c'est pas
parce qu'on est belle qu'on est bien
dans sa peau mais c'est vrai mais
regardez-moi je me sens bien dans mon
corps et pourtant j'ai des doutes
voilà au groupe américain la petite
teinture blonde il y avait un petit
goûter à des livrets à les lire alors
justement parlant de teinture malika il
ya quelqu'un qui a complètement changé
oui il ya quelqu'un alors c'est notre
invité mystère vous avez remarquez bien
sûr que c'était qu'il y fait d'obéir à
la voix voilà même de dos on l'a reconnu
et c'est vrai qu'elle a décidé de
changer de style
elle a décidé si tu un nouveau style
d'un nouveau look pour une nouvelle vie
est magnifique vraiment alors attention
je vous le dis les spectacles on a
reconnu la crème et du tout we do you
drive the home
c'est plus qu'un tel qu'il est avec ses
thèmes chers ça n'est pas une perruque
et ses vrais cheveux sera comme ça
pendant un bon bout de temps ses cheveux
et ses frères qu'ils soient verts et les
verts vd retournez vous
oh non
c'est un changement de ouf avec tact jeu
justement je rejoins ce qu'elle dit et
malika dans le sens où moi je me sentais
vraiment pas bien dans ma peau et
j'avais envie de me retrouver
et là vous êtes retrouvé ma témoin las
vegas et vous avancez tekki une fille
qui se décolorer les cheveux et là ce
sont mes cheveux c'est alors vous êtes
comme ça normalement
là j'ai allongé mais là oui il a fait ça
donc c'est votre vraie couleur donc
kenny n'a jamais été blonde en fait à
bas et jean-michel n'a jamais été chose
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai que là et là vous sentez
bien
ouais bah écoutez moi j'en ai connu
franchement spécialistes voiture de
l'émission bien burger schwarzkopf à
merci et bon en tout cas ben alors
franchement c est sa c6 saisissant mais
voulez moi j'adore moi je ne fais rien
avant ou après j'adore bah moi je alors
je vais vous dire moi je suis dans un
monde où tout le monde il est beau tout
le monde il est temps qu'elle est bien
dans sa peau que c'était exaltant qu'on
va sans dire quand une personne est bien
dans sa peau quand une personne est bien
dans ses baskets
quand une personne est bien dans ses
santiags je suis heureux non mais je
vous le dis c'est comme voilà les jolies
benjamin castadi les yeux fermés ça vous
va bien c'est non mais sans déconner
vous voilà avec kelly si vous êtes vous
êtes bien l'atlas avec le plus de
commentaires ça va être sur les chinois
y aura le film de tarek voilà le cas
mais il y aura les cheveux de kelly
également hashtag bien avancé le
principal qu'est l'isère et s'appelait
alors vous avez fait l'unanimité auprès
des connus alors sachez que 90% des
chroniqueurs sont hypocrites
et mais pas cette fois c'est très beau
facilement